[Musique]
l'aérotrain est un projet très
remarquable et très utile mais qui doit
correspondre un certain besoin
c'est un instrument qui circulent à très
grande vitesse mais transportent un
nombre limité de passagers
je n'ai donc pas un moyen de transport
idéal sur des zones de banlieue et son
établissement sur la ligne de cergy
pontoise à la défense ne correspondait
pas à ce qui est nécessaire pour cette
zone kita a transporté un très grand
nombre de passagers avec une très grande
fréquence et avec des arrêts nombreux
j'imagine au contraire que sur une ligne
comme roissy orly le contournant la
périphérie parisienne l'aérotrain
pourrait correspondre éventuellement à
une justification normal
[Musique]